thank you
um I asked Marty to break this down but
yeah email that
car insurance this is basically the
change right here yep
no change plus one and two point five
correct so you understand that yes no I
don't understand
let's make pictures for people let's
make things well it takes a few days of
looking at it before you kind of wrap
your head around it but once you've
wrapped your head around it then it
starts making sense
mm-hmm
all right representative Pearson you
want to join us
I'd like to thank everybody for being
here this morning thank you we are going
to be looking at
um Amendment 2023-0397h
um a an amendment that basically just
completely replaces HB 436 by
happenstance do do we have a committee
researcher or a committee person
available that can run and grab some
copies of this amendment for folks since
it wasn't
can you go up to fourth floor
we have we have them how many do you
need
ten okay I have five so that's not gonna
quite cut it
just yeah just do 10.
and you also have some input from Mr
Carland that I see various people have
because I didn't get that
the committee yesterday
um
oh good
one to uh Chris and Peter while you're
going by we came up earlier
did you get one trap
I lost mine I left the extra properties
I apologize
foreign
stable we're looking at those like minor
things
a whole bunch of this should be bold
that isn't bold
as far as like the last pages because
it's technically changes and it's all
just in regular writing so somebody else
were to pick it up they would think that
it's just and so so what OLS does is
and I've I've had to deal with this in
my three terms now
is the Bold is in paragraphs where they
make changes then they have a tendency
to not bold new language sometimes right
I don't know why that consistency lacks
uh the last four pages if you just
picked it up you just assume it was in
statute yep exactly page 9 10 11 and 12
should all be bold I agree yeah
hi Marty good
Ness
yeah no worries
um actually Steve well we're waiting for
Carol to come back Marty if you wouldn't
just mind uh well no because Kim's not
here and it would have been for her
benefit
uh just to explain the how the 2.5 or
2.1 percent what that stuff means for
people who aren't reading this every day
you know when they say like a 2.5
multiplier
Yeah
okay or whatever I know you're both on
time constraints yes we are yes
you might as well just sit with me
really I mean
we haven't started yet the uh yeah you
must have just sit with me just so wait
I'm still waiting for Carol to come back
turning around looking for me there she
is right exactly
so all right representative Pearson
let's start digging into this sure
absolutely right from page one where
um basically we're taking what's already
in statute we're splitting it into group
one group two so okay so so back to to
your comment about bold
um like in the in the inconsistencies
that OLS does with Bolding lines five
through seven should be bold
um they really should yep so I'm gonna
make when I when I bring this when we
bring this back down to them we will ask
I will mark this please make this bold
please make the other parts bold yep
but it's you know new language and the
Preamble tells you its new language but
but anyway so based back when we had the
the 2012 lawsuit
um
one of the things that came out of that
was the fact that the statute did not
have a definition of the term vested
it's referenced in the in the statute as
far as qualifications for a benefit on
page like 90 something but not it's not
in the definition list at the beginning
so
looking at the the other New England
states because we are in a competitive
Regional labor market four of the six
New England states vested five years
Massachusetts does not they vest at 10.
we've always operated under the
presumption of 10 the math calculations
the debt everything is based off of of
10.
so in the interest of keeping that
consistent and not causing a massive
upheaval
just leave it at 10 for qualifications
of a benefit but we have a serious trust
problem in the fact that not only from a
reputation point but exteriorly to the
state but within this state the fact
that the legislature went through and
made changes for people that had 10
years in so in the definition of vested
my request here is that or our request
is this is not just me this is a whole
bunch of us that
the two sections average final
compensation and earnable comp be no
there'll be no ability to reduce that
after three years that is so that people
can now have some sort of planning some
sort of idea of what's going on
some sort of commitment from the state
here that you know this is this is what
you expect and this is what we expect in
in
so basically after three years we can't
go back and retroact anything exactly
and that's your four year five year six
year seven that is how we got into this
problem in the beginning so is it a
little bit more bold I suppose than
say having a a tight definition of
vested at five years it is
but we've
not taken the step of arguing for a
five-year vesting like Connecticut Rhode
Island Maine and Vermont right we'll
still say you gotta we want a commitment
for workers to this to this political
subdivisions in the state as well we
what I don't want is for this to become
a hey I'm going to do a five-year jot
and I'm gone and hey I get a little bit
of something you know 35 years from now
we we want people to have careers and
that's
that's why keeping it as a 10-year
minimum denotes that that we want people
to have careers this isn't just a fling
job
right that makes sense uh any questions
on that from yes representative
I might as well leave my mic on
[Laughter]
well we can only have three of us
representative I think I know what best
it means
I work for a company and in 10 years my
stock options are vested they're mine
now but they weren't mine at nine years
right
what are we talking about what can't be
reduced after three years the the
agreement that they had when they
started so say we were going to give you
a specific plan when you started all
right and then you've worked three years
once you reached that third year mark we
can't change that plan on you anymore
what you agreed to originally it's about
the formula yeah the way that we got
into the problem that we're in right now
is some people had worked nine and a
half years with a with an agreement in
place they thought that they were
getting a benefit and then we came in
and said no just kidding you never had
that benefit so the way that I like to
explain it's kind of like you come to
work for me and I agree to pay you 30 an
hour and I'm paying you thirty dollars
an hour and then nine and a half years
later I come and say just kidding it was
15 an hour no by the way you got to give
me that fifteen dollars back it's not a
hundred percent the same way but it's
it's kind of that idea that's not really
that's not a bad a good choice it's it's
only about the the pension benefits they
can't change your pension benefit after
you have worked for three years so if
you work for two and a half years and
they say your pension is now half of
what it was
that's it for three years your pension
benefit
calculation is Frozen it's frozen
I I and I think that might be a good
thing to put in to make it more explicit
that you're talking about the pension
benefit
well it does it references both
paragraphs specifically this is both of
them um so um I'll ask Marty to explain
also what what as far as what you're
entitled to
if you as far as like employee
contribution and that kind of thing yeah
sure um so a little bit of background
vesting in in retirement system you know
parlance is once you've completed 10
years of creditable service you've
earned the right to a future benefit so
whether you work another 10 20 30 years
or whether you stop working and then
come back to us when you're eligible by
age for that benefit you're vested as
long as you keep your contributions with
us you can come back to us when you're
eligible to collect a benefit and get
something based on your term of service
and your salary during that time so so
that's that's what vesting means you
know for us and back in 2011 when the
legislature you know opened up the
retirement system and made a lot of
changes
um that that legislature at the time
drew the line at vested anybody who was
not in the system less than 10 years uh
there's a lot of opinions on how that
was adjudicated in court behind me
um and I'm not here to comment on you
know I'm not a lawyer and and wouldn't
interpret that but you know so that
that's the line that legislature Drew
um this this provision here would freeze
that after three years of service if
there were future changes if you were
going to increase the member
contribution rates which is for example
right now for fire it's 11.8 percent of
pay if a future legislature wanted to
increase that to 12 and a half percent
of pay again just for for the sake of
argument this provision would prevent
that change from affecting anybody who
had three or more years in the system
you know when that change was enacted so
it would affect those people with less
than three years in future hires is that
your understanding representative
poke me if I'm saying anything that you
think is incorrect so okay but also so
one second real quick so you mentioned
there the contribution rate wouldn't
change
either
change because that paragraph's not
covered okay okay I was going to say
because that could cut both ways bad
example so the the number of years you
need to work to retire right is it
better example you know it's that that
makes sense I'm sorry no no that's fine
I want to restrict the contribution to
be potentially flexible in case we have
a a problem so that's not restricted
um the other thing to answer your
question representative true is has to
do with the what the employee puts in
from day one if they don't make ten
years and if you can cover what they get
back if they leave yeah sure thing so if
a member leaves service
um before vesting so they don't have 10
Years yet they've worked you know one
year or nine years or whatever the case
may be uh they have the choice to take a
refund of their accumulated
contributions plus interest credited on
it you know during their period of
service as a lump sum they can take that
as a um you know a check from us and pay
the take the tax hit or they could roll
it over into a qualified retirement plan
um they don't have to if somebody works
nine years and has to leave employment
for whatever reason whether they were
laid off or they had a life issue
they're dealing with a family thing or
whatever if they kept their money with
us that would preserve their nine years
of service and their original hire date
if they came back in another position
and worked a few more years you know to
vest you know they could still do that
so so our we call them terminated
members they're not active anymore but
they still have money with us and
there's there's
um uh several people there they would
still get interest on those
contributions at the same rate as active
members while they have the money with
us but basically if somebody worked five
years and took their money out they're
no longer a member they never existed in
nhrs view you know for the purposes of
retirement if they came back and took
another job that would be their initial
higher date and they'd be subject to
whatever the plan Provisions were at the
time of that higher date
yeah
anyone so
um
I worked nine years and now I'm gonna go
do something else
I can take out what I put in not my
employer correct whatever I put in
and I can reinvest that somewhere else
or I could leave it there
and at some future date I'll get a small
pension
not not unless you return to service and
got at least 10 years in
um you know so you know if somebody is
not planning to come back they worked
eight years and they own their own
business now and they're never coming
back if they keep their money with us or
almost treating it as a savings account
is there a time limit on that does it
does the system eventually cash it out
without you but that was repealed about
20 years ago by the legislature it's
just if if I'm
if I'm not going to get a small pension
from that nine years put in why would I
leave the money
for a couple of reasons the first reason
is you think you might come back to work
at some point in which case you really
want you really want to keep your
starting date and the conditions
and
and your contributions will have grown
so you will be in that way you'll
capture the nine years of employer
contributions as well correct so if you
if you have even a small chance of
coming back to work for the state it
will be worth it to have an earlier
start date and nine years of accumulated
contributions a great example of this is
is a teacher who becomes pregnant and
takes 10 years off to raise their
children and then comes back to teach
that that's probably the most common
example of how that occurs it's not
really dot workers or folks like that
but it but especially within teachers
um that it's in essence they can pause
and and compared to what we have now
that is new
no it is it's been there since the
beginning just the just the definition
the definition wasn't in statute so we
were yeah we were working as if it were
in statute almost um under the
assumption that that was the case but
they're just putting it in there now so
that we have something technical to work
with
yes Kim representative here
if I recognize you you can talk
thank you
so representative Pearson do I
understand this correctly that the there
is no change on the the vesting that
we've been discussing it's just putting
it in there as to what it what defining
it that's not that would not be entirely
accurate the 10-year qualification for a
benefit is no change that is the
presumption well it's not a presumption
because the qualifications for benefit
at 10 years is in the statute it's just
not defined it occurs
like an A5 I think it's referenced in in
both accidental disability and now
vested deferred retirement it's so it's
you know and possible and then in the
debt in the death benefits it you know
it's it's it's it's it's it's reference
elsewhere in the statute where it's
applicable but it was never added to the
definitions at the beginning but it's
it's and that's that's how it's inferred
and been and also too since it's under
those three specific sections this under
definitions would just make it a CR in
the entire document rather than because
you could interpret it that it only
applies to the the paragraphs in which
it exists which is part of the problem
we had in the court case in 20 2012.
it also it also adds the three-year and
that's the second part that's the
three-year part is new
yeah sure
thank you so
I asked Marty to provide me with some
real life examples so that we could
understand this and so in I know that
you have a copy of this um one second
Tim uh we're going to come back to that
later thanks yep yeah we'll get chopped
this up we'll get Section by section
yep
so that's that is
would it be fair to say that this simply
puts the assumed definition of vested
among the definitions and then adds a
new clause about the three years after
three years you can't mess with these
two calculations correct okay yep
that that was a back that was a a back
office ask of a judge
to
to Define it please define it and I'm
shocked that it took us a decade frankly
to to do it so Now's the Time so after
that after we get past that part
um we go into splitting group one from
group two correct
um if you look at line 10 group one it's
basically the definition that's on the
Statue right now but it's just siphoning
it off group two so that we can do
something different with group two
correct that paragraph does have a
request from retirement to remove line
21 that sentence slightly before and
after 21 because it is irrelevant to
group one it's a language cleanup thing
that's a specific thing to group two so
it shouldn't be there right that's at
their request so that's fine yep that
makes sense
um similarly to if if I can keep going
because we haven't ended the paragraph
it runs over into page two yes similarly
line one permanent firemen line two
permanent policeman does not need to be
in a group one definition because they
are not in group one right same request
from retirement and what was the what
was the purpose uh in line
um 25 for striking the compensation part
which page uh two page two oh the
purpose of that is because
you have what it says is
in this paragraph do what's in the next
paragraph well the next paragraph tells
you to do it so it's it's just
completely redundant okay
it does
uh yeah because uh online
uh what does it starts at the end of
line 20. the reference to extra and
special duty pay that's specifically a
pay available only to the group two
members so a reference the extra
inspection or special Duty and special
Duty pays are relevant to group one
because they're not right under current
law they you know they don't get it so
that is a request to remove for a
language cleanup online 20. yep yeah
there's there's I mean there's a bunch
of that I'm not sure that we have to hit
all of those necessarily at line 27 on
page three teachers employees that
doesn't need to be in there there's
there's a few of them that overlaps but
um if any member of the committee would
like to see the highlighted version from
nhrs we have one with all of those
little extra special Duty doesn't belong
in here because it's group two and
there's no sensitive change to the to
policy right cost or procedure just
doing a better job separating group one
and group two than I than I did when I
wrote it that was
that was factor or the benefits for
anybody right yeah no I noticed them
last night when I was going through it
as well just
things here and there
[Music]
um
I'm not sure how much time the committee
has spent looking at the document any
questions on page two
yes representative true
for me personally
um
what I want hope to get from this
meeting is not an understanding of of
the pension system because we'd have to
be here a little bit longer than my
lifetime exists what I need to know is
what's different sure that that's what
I'm that's what I want to cause
the way it is now because of the changes
from 10 years ago whenever yep
what's the difference what's the cost
that's that's what I'm that's what I'm
looking for sure starting on page three
yep just so page three is is where the
split
um really comes in you know so that and
that's why it's bold so the so to
separate group one and group two we have
to add another paragraph to create the
split
so in here um there was removal
because it if you look at it literally
word for word references to teachers the
university teaching system doesn't need
to be in there
um that the end of line 10 needs to come
out because we don't do that line page
State yep line 27 where it says employee
teachers that at the request of
retirement will come out so just for
just for clarification purposes too what
this does representative true if you
look at the first line on line seven it
says status prior to January 1st 2013
that used to say January 1st 2012. okay
and then this whole paragraph this whole
explanation or definition
um of what calculates into their benefit
is exactly what it was before we made
the change to the new system so it's
reverting people for that year back to
the old system of retirement pay their
old package correct their original
package their original plan they had
when they were hired the one that they
had when they were hired so this just
brings one year one one year of people
the last year the year that should be
retiring right now and says that they
can retire right now
with the package that they were promised
when they started does that make sense
yes Carol
sorry representative
we can be informal uh I'm concerned
about that because that is essentially
telling everybody that
was at the nine plus years in 2011 that
they can retire right now and if I
accept except it doesn't because the if
the effective date of this
is out
and it's actually going to require an
additional year of service
okay so this is section
one
take effect January 2024 so that we
should expect on January 1st 2024 a wave
of retirements of people that were in
this group not necessarily it gives them
the option it's it certainly doesn't
tell them to do that
but it gives them the option sure as it
would them just reaching the goal or the
the qualifications to retire well I I
happen to be have been working at
Lockheed when they implemented a change
to the retirement system
and oh a significant fraction of people
that were planning to work in other year
or three or five said
oh if I work longer I'm going to be my
benefit will be decreased so I'm
retiring right now and we lost
hundreds of people that month because
they decide they calculated that it
would be better off to retire now than
to work another year or two so this
forces a year they could actually leave
right now they would just leave under
the current calculation so there's an
incredible incentive for them to to give
an additional year of service and under
the current statute the value to stay is
less
than the change so so the carrot is
there to say if you keep going it's
worth more to stay than it used to be
and that's what we're trying to do is as
you're well aware the it's the longer
someone works the better it is for the
system thank you for pointing that out
yep
I may have to say so I totally agree
with you that that will act as that
incentive that you've just described but
representative McGuire's point was that
next year we're very likely to see that
wave because people are I think that's
what's going to happen but people will
say I can retire now with what has been
promised and they can't yank the rug out
from underneath me once I've retired
because
that's locked in at that point so I I do
think we have we're good we have to
anticipate that we'll see a wave sure
and not a guarantee right take it well
and I I don't I want to be careful not
to isolate just that first year either
because the chart stretches out farther
than just the first year sure and and so
you're incentivizing future years to to
stay on as well
um when they might just stop to get out
earlier
um so we are with what this amendment
does I think actually is systematically
spreads out the risk of departure rather
than I think we actually maybe run a
higher risk of a larger departure so
earlier in the trial in the trouble
called the trottier bill I forget the
number 549 or whatever it was that that
would have happened because you would
have instantaneously moved a decades
worth of people
immediately to to a retirement point
where you would see a mass Exodus this
this goes in the other direction and
says no because we don't we don't want
that to happen now keep in mind
as of February 1st
last week the first group of folks could
start to exit we could have the mass
Exodus anyway
and there are probably some folks that
are so burned out that they're not going
to wait that year but this is this is a
substantial carrot to say please please
keep working and this is what we're
gonna because because of the abundance
of things but the majority being the
labor market that we have and also too
by forcing someone to work that
additional year it's better for the
system
because they're not withdrawing a
benefit they're actually putting money
into the system
and that's that's the incentive
sure but I mean at some point regardless
of where you were to draw a line that's
going to happen at some point anyway so
either we either we get them to stay the
year or we do nothing and we see a mass
Exodus without the care from my
perspective on this without the carrot
they just leave sooner they just leave
sooner they just leave sooner
so
um so so on page four section D because
just correct me if I just for
clarifications for purposes Steve this
this bill doesn't change
the
um when somebody can retire in group two
it just incentives up incentivizes them
to stay longer if they want a higher
pension correct so they can they can
still retire when they were gonna be
able to retire they'll just take the the
package they're on now they won't get
the new new package that's proposed in
this that is why I wrote it right this
way that is why the group of us that
conferred did it this way because what I
did not want is to get into a similar
situation that we're in right now with
mandatory overtime where we're literally
forcing people to work
you know scenario that is really close
to slave labor by threatening people's
jobs and and whatnot by forcing them to
come in on this mandatory I didn't want
to exacerbate that by saying we're going
to force you to do a year right we're
going to ask you this is what you get in
return
I just I just want to make sure
everybody in the committee understands
we're not offering to allow people to
leave sooner correct they're able to
leave when they were already able to
leave but we're just trying to
incentivize that discount around a
little bit longer yep
um so that language follows through
to the bottom of page four correct yep
it's a so a paragraphs A and B repeated
c and d right the separation of group
one and group two uh at a request lines
12 and 28 contain the word teacher they
shouldn't be in there that that will
come out
because there's no need of that
yeah there's there's a yeah on line 12
there there's a few of them
so any questions from any member of the
committee so far on that concept because
now we're going to go into
um
final compensation average yes
representative
so with uh with what we were just
discussing
uh trying to encourage people to work a
little longer
can somebody give me what does a little
longer mean
so uh to you I mean I could probably use
the the what you what it uses an example
here so do we want to wait until we just
get to the chart to answer that question
would that be easier I'm
his mind it's fine so what happens what
happens is is that if if I if I earned a
50 000 benefit right
for that year I take fifty thousand
dollars out of the system but if I work
not only am I not taking fifty thousand
out I have to contribute based on my
salary so I'm instead of removing 50 000
out of the system I'm putting 12 000 in
it's a full it's a full Switcheroo if
you will
um if you were a fan of the National
League double double Switcheroo but the
so that has a financial
it's a substantial Financial difference
because
I'm not drawing out but I'm actually
contributing
you can't lock I can't give you a rock
hard example other than the hypothetical
50 000 because every single person
that's in the pension system
has a different salary has different
years of service
what might be simpler is that if you
retire right now
you will get 2.1 percent of your average
final compensation 2.4
2.4 2.4
if you re if you wait a year until this
goes into effect you will receive 2.5
times your average final salary times
your years of service so you'll have not
only one more year of service you will
also get
per year per year well so you'll you
will get a bonus in your pension which
is
you know like four percent a four
percent increase in your pension plus an
extra year service so so one year Chris
I think is what you were asking you
we're incentivizing them to stay an
extra year
yes correct now as far as incentivizing
it's it's a little bit more than it's a
minimum of a year that they would have
to do beyond that the incentive still
continues right for them to continue
working so I don't want to I don't want
this framed into like just a one-year
framework it's it goes beyond that but
it's it requires a minimum of one year
right to achieve it to achieve it
correct
and maybe people will feel a little less
burnt out if they're getting paid better
who knows
people's internal internal value of what
they contribute to their employer
matters I mean there's been plethora of
studies involving raises the concept of
raises the concept of value employee
production based on how they feel
they're valued in an organization
and I can tell you at least in that
category right now in my 20 plus years
of being in the in the services in New
Hampshire I don't think it's ever been
lower it is it is just almost rock
bottom right now and this would go a
tremendously long way in improving that
without any further objection I'll move
we'll move on to uh average final
compensation really on page five is
where where our stuff comes in
so at a request of the retirement system
pretty much the second half of paragraph
a which is lines one through five
they want gone because it doesn't it
doesn't apply to group one
so that's a request of of uh the
retirement system that makes sense it's
just it's inappropriate language for
that yep
group one with only the one sentence
on pay at the bottom of page four
correct and that matches frankly the
original sentence that existed from 1967
to 2010. which was which was literally
one sentence
for for group two
that language does matter so that's why
it is in bold line six through fourteen
it is a repeat of what what was in
status literally in status it's word for
word with the only difference being
divested the one year as we begin down
that road otherwise it's verbatim as to
what it was now this um
this is part of a compromise because
it's leaving in a change
that did not occur when these people
hire were hired and that involves an
anti-spiking provision
so the anti-spiking provision remains
um
we all are well or at least
representative McGuire is well aware it
that the anti-spiking provisions were
for the most part put into place because
they were needed and
I what we don't want to do is upset that
so the so those even though
realistically they should be taken out
for folks because they were not enacted
until 2009 that is a compromise to
prevent a repeat of problems yeah I'd
like to mention that when we looked into
spiking at various occasions
over the last 15 years at least we found
that most
people worked who worked a lot of
overtime in their last few years also
worked a lot of overtime in their
earlier years so this would not affect
anybody who consistently worked overtime
it would only affect people who said Gee
I can jack up my pension by working a
lot in the last year or two I mean one
of my personal friends was a fireman in
San Francisco and in his last year of
service he told us well we I won't be
seeing you for the next year because I'm
going to be working all the overtime and
extra shifts that I can pull because it
was going to spike his pension and it
did in fact give him a substantial
benefit because that pension system
allowed it
so he got I think an extra extra 10 10
15 000 a year by
basically working full-time
20 24 7 his last year of service
so and we don't want that to happen it's
unfair to the people and it's
but it's unfair to both the people who
pay for the pension and the and the
people that are trying to manipulate it
representative
um
I I said it before on committee and it's
not unjust
um speak to me as if I were a child
speak to me as if I were a golden
retriever or a pet turtle I have no idea
what spiking is so I can give you a
phenomenal example Okay so
you work 17 years
in your job
and you look at the way that the system
used to function and say hey you know
what for the next three years if I just
do a hundred hours a week I will inflate
my pension to to a number that really
doesn't really jive with the prior 17
years I worked and that in their that's
what they a lot of people did they and
the divorce rate was was horrible that I
mean this this led to burned out people
it led to to folks that were just became
kind of horrible workers because they
were you know in in the interest of of
greed I guess you would call it or the
interests of gaming the system they just
never went home all they did was work
and what happens with that is that yes
they contribute into the system for that
time period based on an elevated salary
but the way that the pension sensor
functions it it's not the Investments
over time the way the system works it
can't handle that so it's detrimental to
the Corpus of the fund as a whole
so when they looked at this back a
decade 14 years ago
in conjunction with the retirement
system that you they said okay this is
this is dangerous to the health of the
system and we need to put some things in
place to prevent this from occurring
further
that's recognized
one of the things that for those that
care about this system we certainly
don't want to see the system fall apart
we don't want to see this system default
and the anti-spiking provisions that
were put in place frankly work the
health of the the system has gotten
substantially healthier just in the last
four years we've we've increased our
assets by several billion
so there's no desire to to make a change
to go back to something we know is
hurtful
yeah it also we also the other issue
with spot with that kind of spiking is
you end up with people retiring with
outrageous out looking salaries and they
make the newspaper and a lot of people
assume that all retirees are collecting
150 000 a year when it's only those who
manipulated the system to get more extra
two things Mr chair
um so anti-spiking is somewhere on the
bottom of four and top of five
anti-spiking is throughout the document
there's several other things that occur
too this just happens to be one of those
Provisions yeah he was just saying that
the language is still in there don't
exist but but what keeps the system from
allowing them to do that is in the
document
and and uh in testimony he said well and
what just we're going to take our
teachers
I haven't been taken out teacher are we
looking at another amendment that's
going to take out a lot yes
it won't change any of the language that
affects benefits
removing teachers from some of the group
two language and removing and vice versa
it went both ways yeah
and as as Retirement stated that that
doesn't change the concept of substance
the cost it's a language cleanup that's
and that's all it is it really probably
wouldn't have any practical if it was
left in there it would
just be messy yeah that's all and that
and that bothers Marty so we don't want
to do that there are no group two
team firemen
that's all that is although the teachers
might come up with an extra Duty
something
or something else yes is your particular
or instructional pay yeah
so the the paragraph C is just a
renaming of a paragraph
because we you know can't have two
paragraph B's
um the paragraph d
it goes along with the consistency of
moving that date forward a year at a
time
uh in paragraph two
one of the things that I I removed here
or we removed here I keep saying I
shouldn't is
um
I've never been comfortable with that
line that's crossed out because if you
started on July 1 of 11 January 1 of 12
is six months later there is
it's almost impossible for that to
scenario to exist I don't like it I
think it's confusing in the interest of
having a firm Line in the Sand
see ya so
so that should conclude page five yep
page six is so A5 paragraph A5 in the
statute which is predominantly what page
six is about has to do with
qualifications of you know when you're
allowed to earn your pension
so all there's no policy no
language changes at all it's just a date
change
to start the process of transitioning
people back
no other language has changed in A5
whatsoever
until we get to
Part D which is on page seven
this Infamous chart that everybody
has nightmares about both from an
employer employee and retirement system
standpoint
so the chart
what what we the change in the chart is
simply to take the chart apart
that's it it doesn't change anything in
the chart but it takes it from
four categories to ten because if you're
going to annually move someone
if you don't do that then you're moving
two years of people
disproportionately
the the FI you know the line 20 Which is
less than four years would be the
movement of four people simultaneously
and therefore one group would only have
to work
X number of years and the rest of them
would have to work more so this is just
an equity thing if you're going to move
people annually you have to take the
chart apart to to do that so this this
separates
the transition
from two to two one-year groups correct
that's all it does yep the rest of the
math is the first group from four years
done to individual well yeah it was
originally four years this is taken
apart yeah it goes it just makes it one
year increments is all it does
uh let's see yeah and you have to I mean
you really have to do that once you
start pulling it pulling them out one
year at a time because we're gonna go
one year at a time so you go exactly you
got to be impossible there's no other
way to do it that would be and again
we're supposed to be writing law here
where people regular folks can read this
and kind of get an understanding so if
it was written into some bizarre
legalese goo
Marty would be getting to phone calls
all the time trying how it's bad enough
they're asking for interpretations as it
is I don't want to make that worse so
this just simplifies that for folks that
go on to the Internet and try to figure
this master they're still going to call
but that's okay massive document out
sure so where we where we get into a
little bit more substantive changes here
is now in 186 which is the pension cap
the pension cap was instituted in 2009
prior to that there was no cap of any
type
where are you page eight
twenty six line 26. starting on line 13.
which is section a 100 RSA 186.
so the first part mirrors the problem
that I had with the prior paragraph in
that
um
if we're going to have a definitive Line
in the Sand
then it needs to just read that way
when you get to
the second part
what we're looking at here is
adhering to the idea of penalties or
calculations that didn't exist when
these folks started the the lesser of 85
percent of a member's average final
compensation are 120 000 did not exist
until 2009.
so this just basically in the interest
of keeping
a definitive line of July 1 of 11.
puts that little line right there the
folks that were hired before July 1 of
01 that never had a cap of any type will
continue under that Realm
so it basically puts a pension cap into
three categories
prior to o1 01 to 11 and an 11 on
so the people we were dealing with the
transitional 10-year they're getting a 5
bump in their cap in in 120 000 in 2009
equals 166 385 dollars today if you look
at the 38.6 percent inflation for this
District over that time
so the 125 is really just because I like
round numbers and it seems like a round
number so
by right if you wanted to make things
whole it would be 166 166 000 pension to
me is outrageous so I'm not going to
make the argument that
but I want you to understand though that
that with the rest of this is Essence is
somewhat of a compromise because it's
reducing real dollar value
yeah I I understand the 125
000.
um
the less but you're deleting the lesser
of 85 percent of the members average
final compensation only for folks in the
2011 group The the new hires that is a
condition that existed when they were
hired and that remains in paragraph C
which is the the 2011 and on folks so
that someone
in the transition could work long enough
to get a hundred percent of their
average final compensation well that is
the the and that is the maximum cap
um you cannot go beyond 100 of that it
doesn't say so
it says they can't exceed 125.
in this and there's yeah there's a and
there's a hard number at 125 000. I get
that but I think that it if you're going
to be essentially changing that 85 to
100 I think you should leave it there
because
I I that is a policy choice
that's true there's no reason why if I
think according to that language if
their benefit was going to be 85 that
they couldn't just give them 125 if they
wanted to it's not capped at 100 percent
I'm not entirely sure what you're asking
here so my point is that 85 of final
compensation yeah is a limit of one sort
and then there's a hard dollar correct
except all right if you want to say that
someone who has been a long Service
employee can continue to earn up to a
hundred percent of their final salary
gotcha then say so okay so change the 85
to 100. I think yeah that would be more
okay
by all means yeah
and just just to clarify
um under the two and a half percent
multiplier for group uh group two the
original tra folks excuse me once
somebody works 40 years at two and a
half percent a year they've accrued a
hundred percent of their average final
compensation we've had some Chiefs
who've worked beyond that
um you know and um you know but so and
so if if it was 85 that would be 34 at
two and a half percent that's 34 years
so that that's how that that's how
someone could get to a hundred percent
of AFC is by working you know extremely
long and I certainly don't want to say
say Hey you worked 34 years bye-bye that
again encouraging people to work longer
is better for the system shutting them
off at 34 years and I think there are
other Provisions that say that after
you've worked 40 years you you stop
contributing
no actually I was just going to say that
the member doesn't contribute after
they've maxed out we still think the
town yeah
is that just because that exists would
you stop doing that
otherwise
well there's nothing in the stature that
would allow us to not collect employer
contributions on the salary of active
members so regardless of whether it's
they have one year of service or 50.
okay that makes sense and and putting it
leaving in the percent of final
compensation but setting it at 100 would
mean that
members with 40 years of service will
continue to be eligible to not
contribute anymore
otherwise if it's just a flat dollar
amount there's no reason to do so
sure that makes sense okay I get you
there so the other thing that's here is
that in in uh retirement provided this
chart in their explanation page as to
what a one and a quarter percent annual
increase in the cap looks like
uh just so that you could understand
the the hard math without having to do
it yourself
um
the
what we have seen and especially in
reference to a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars equaling 166 today is
that if we don't have some kind of
mechanism to adjust that number
those dollars become old
and this is no at one and a quarter
percent we are nowhere near inflation
nowhere near it but at least at at least
this provides a mechanism for it to move
forward it doesn't it also prevents the
pension cap from also being a ceiling
eventually where if you get to that
point go hey I'm at my 125 you know 15
18 years from now see ya I gotta go I'm
not you know I'm not working for free so
it prevents that from happening as well
but just keep in mind that they ran
these numbers out to 2036 and you're
still not at 166 000 you're still not
even at today's dollars so this is just
any further inflation adjustment would
take place in the compensation line
sure you know or or if this really fell
behind drastically in the future the
legislature certainly has the right to
come in and adjust it that's they would
not be restricted from doing that at all
so but it's just a mechanism to not to
prevent a stagnant dollar
is all that it is
any questions from the committee
Chris
I feel so sorry for you guys that having
me on your committee not at all I I
welcome the questions representative
truce seriously um you're brave enough
to ask them and there are probably lots
of other people that are saying I wonder
what that means but don't dare to ask
are we trying to work in some proof uh
that uh to prevent inflation from
weakening your dollar is we can't do
that no no no no that's not it go ahead
sir not it no not at all it's just
saying so and I'll give you a real world
example in 1994
there was a uh
was a Manchester Battalion Chief and and
I'll only use this as a reference
because it was on the front page of the
union leader he earned a 25 000 a year
pension and that the union leader was
deframed as outrageous
if 25 the poverty level in New Hampshire
is 44 000. my property taxes are 10
grand 25 000 pension now would be I
would be in a heap of trouble so you the
dollar as the dollar moves and the in
the the value of the dollar
changes through through inflation
anytime you have something that's a hard
number
every year that number becomes less and
less of a value
if there had been a pension caps
introduced in 1994 of 25 000 we the
legislature would have had to have
amended that multiple times because you
would have just had Mass retirements
when people hit the sale so for
clarification again we didn't have a
pension cap we didn't exist then we
instituted one back in 2000 2009 correct
and so once we instituted that pension
cap it locked the pension in time it
froze it in time and to know how no
matter how much inflation happens you
could only get 125. this is just saying
that as the years go on the cap that and
the cap is going to be somewhat
controlled by what we're paying them
right so I mean
um they're not just going to be able to
get a higher pension just because the
cap goes up we'd have to be paying them
more for them to get a larger pension to
reach that cap limit it just says that
the dollar tomorrow isn't going to be
worth what it is today so the cap should
be a little bit higher
um so that they can get they can get a
pension that's in line with the value of
the work that they did and in line with
their with their pay right with their
pay the procedure used here and I asked
OLS about this because I'm not I'm like
you know is this ordered correctly is
this something that can be done in
statute and I was assured that there are
multiple places in statute that have
annual ratchetings of things this is not
unique in any way and
um
in the future it just saves us from
having to it's going to save us some
headaches exactly
yeah go ahead of course
this new wording is saying that the
maximum
pensions you can get is 125.
yes that would be the maximum for this
year and then next year in January 1 of
2025 sorry it would go to 126 563 which
is one and a quarter percent above 125
000.
yep now keep in mind every year of
service someone Works they get two and a
half percent this is half of that so at
some point in the in the rabbit and hair
race it's it's possible to have a
collision that would have you leave what
we're saying is we don't want the the
the tortoise to not move period
and once again Chris just for
clarification purposes almost nobody
gets up that high at this point like
yeah very very very very rare for that
to happen the average ones are way way
less it's controlled by what the
municipality is paying
um so that's that's within a Town's
purview as to say what they want to pay
because the employee the employees
paying in at a rate the employers paying
at the rate at a rate they're the ones
paying in and so they're the ones who
are setting what the person's going to
get together we're not setting that for
them yes some um you know the you know
the way the the cap is written now you
had to be uh hired after seven one of 09
and not vested by one one of twelve two
hit it so there are a few people
retiring now
um who are getting locked pensions and
in excess of 120 000. I I look quickly
at the list just over 125 there's
currently 39 retirees receiving a
pension over 125 right now I'm not sure
I'm sure there's a few between 120 20
and 25 but those are people who
were hired invested prior to the effect
of the the 120 cap and that's probably
people who retired at a high rate of pay
and worked for 40 years or so yeah yeah
it's primarily group two I think there's
a school superintendent in the list as
well or somebody who retired as a
teacher so I'm assuming they're a
superintendent maybe they were principal
but again it's all your your pensions
are based on years of service and your
average final salary so it it you know
depending on people who have a lot of
service tend to be at the top of their
profession and their community and are
among the highest paid or the highest
paid individuals in those towns so that
that's the math is the math nobody gets
any deals to get those pensions they
they earn them under the current law
yeah so if you don't want it in your
town just don't pay your people that
much so I I have a question for you
Marty um of the 39 pensioners above this
how many active retire how many retirees
exist how many thousands of retirees do
we have to give you an idea of numbers
yeah we've got about 42 000 benefit
recipients and I I what I crunch every
year for our slides and other handouts
is uh the percentage of of retirees
earning a benefit in excess of 75 000 I
mean I could slice and dice other levels
if if you need me to next week but
that's less than two percent of the the
42 000 total benefits paid uh 94 of
people receiving a benefit now it's
under 50.
so so just to put the framework 39
people in 42 000. it's a there's a lot
of zeros before you hit a number after
that decimal please and that was the
choice of the municipality that hired
them yep so so but again just to prevent
you know when you have the opportunity
to to fix a couple of things when you're
in here when you're when you're going to
open this statute up
it's time to do like language again
reference to language changes definition
improvements things like that if you're
gonna if you're going to do it just fix
fix the things you know need to be fixed
now so we're not we're not coming back
next term going hey we got to do let's
do some language cleanups let's just get
it out of the way now and I think the
stagnant pension cap is one of those I
mean you might I I'm not a question of
whether you like it or not you might not
like it but do you get it
so
there are people who have an exorbitant
pension payout there's a couple I mean
lesson you couldn't put put them on a
school bus yep and that's what's trigger
those people are the ones who got
exorbitant pay when they were working
but this cap says that won't happen
again correct that's exactly what that
cap says it cannot happen again okay and
part of that came through the spiking
that we were talking about earlier you
know like they they would they would put
in that extra time at the end to really
drive it up
yes Kim
so
with a tier two member
who before this bill
was
having a multiplier of
0.021 now has 0.025
and they're extended from 24 years to 25
years
and the difference where are you we're
you're back on the chart yeah I'm I'm on
my chart I'm trying to apply to
understand if I thoroughly understand
what this did
yes well we haven't gotten there yet I
think it'll be clearer when we get to
page well the next one right yeah it's
going to start kicking in the next video
the boilerplate part kicks in right at
the bottom you'll see how it affects the
chart
so
the boilerplate the legalese part you
know where I got more Roman numerals
than in Athens
government building right here but
um what this but it's the same every
character it is it is what this does is
it says every year
we're going to transition people back
into the system to which they were hired
under that is how we make them work the
additional year
is it with effective dates so
every annually
every January 1 a new group of people
now has the carrot officially has the
carrot dangled in front of them if they
choose and like I said before in the
event that they're burned out or
something happens or they they move
whatever they just have to go they'll
just have to go under the current math
formula instead of the the incentivized
one so if you look at
um
let's just go to let's pick one yeah
yeah just pick one um
part seven
that's the first one
um you'll see that yeah top of page nine
uh line three it'll say subsequent
change is effective January 1st 2025. so
on January 1st 2025 this will go into
effect and before that in fact this is
one of the interesting things about this
is it amends itself like nine times and
so you got to keep up with it as it goes
along because every year it changes this
document changes itself every year so on
2025 all right the effective date that
we started with which was um
2013 2013 2013. if you look down on line
five that every time 2013 shows up as
the effective debate now it's going to
be 2014. so at that point the group on
line 27 of the chart
uh less than one or line yeah line no
line 28. yeah
um is going to go from
yeah just gets deleted and that
yeah then those people would go back to
the 2.5 multiplier
and then the next year it'll get pushed
back a year and that next line on the
chart will go back to 2.5 percent and
then the next year the next group will
go to 2.5 it just keeps rolling it back
year after year after year until in 33
the chance it's obsolete and then and we
get rid of the language the language
gets the language reverts to instead of
having a term of vested it just says you
are hired but before July 1 of 11 or you
are hired after so you'll see that on
page 10 uh starting on line 25 you'll
start to see that where it says any
reference to 2021 that's because the LA
that's the last group's effective date
so that's where it will be it at that
point the statute will all say effective
2021 and then we're going to come in and
get rid of that and change the language
to
um who commenced service on 2011. so
it'll essentially split everybody into
two groups the people who started
serving before 2011 and the people who
started serving after 2011. does that
make sense and the final the final one
is actually only a six month move
because it goes from January to July so
it's but that's just it's a consistent
procedure annually
across the board the the with no
surprises because it's literally a
paragraph repeat eight times they found
that
to reference it using the the sections
in Roman numerals this way made this an
11 page document instead of a 50 page
document
and much easier for us to follow oh it's
easier
I I'd like to say that I really
appreciate that it is self
amending and it includes the entire
transition group
so that
everybody knows that we're taking care
of the whole group with this bill we're
not just taking care of this year's
property because what will happen is
they'll we're just going to keep coming
back and no and the speaker the speaker
was very clear he looked at me and said
how do I how can I can this problem be
solved and I said yes and he said can
you do it and I said I think so and this
solves the problem and we're done with
this
it's just going to take a little time
now as far as the the money part of this
um
the
we referenced the trout of your bill is
the maximum amount because that
instantly moved everyone back
with no concessions the fiscal note has
dropped on that and it is lower than
even what you would because it was
brought in at 249 it's actually 229.
229 129 million
before any concessions the speaker will
be very happy instantly did it
so as far as the what those concessions
bring to the financial part of that they
have to run an Actuarial on this after
so just
possibly under 200.
you know just when you look at it just
sort of as back of the envelope math and
there's some changes a little bit in in
this bill compared to the referred to as
a trading bill because I don't recall
the number I think it was 525.
um you know so so in all of our brains
it seems like it is but Actuarial math
is a little bit like particle physics
you know the laws of gravity and things
don't quite apply the same way right or
or non-existent there so I I'd be
foreign missed to put a number or even
an estimate on it at this point sure but
we did um it should definitely be less
the funding on line 28 of page 11.
should be enough to cover it
that's what it feels like in in human
terms and so we will I think we should
leave that alone and let the actuarius
go to actuaries go to work well yeah no
the good news is though by the time if
we can get this through the house the
first time by the time it gets to
finance we should have that number and
they can amend us to match that number
if they need to or they could just put a
little extra in or they can just put on
especially in a down stock market
right because because it's not even
though it the concept is a flat fund the
reality is is that
Market changes later right as the market
improves
this number
could drop based on Market Improvement
in all that so you know just like the
rest of the system does right so the
actuaries are are I'm not gonna I'm not
going to devalue what they do for a
career by referring to them as as is
financial weathermen but they kind of
are in a way because they have to make
assumptions on some things in the future
based on a a best guess and as we have
seen in the last especially the last
four years the actuaries have become
more and more conservative in their
thinking
with with attaching a little bit higher
cost to things
so that we kind of almost guarantee we
don't get into trouble right well and
the difference with this though is we're
funding this we're not we're not sending
this back to the municipalities this is
coming right out of the general fund so
correct it's a little bit different that
way too as far as like the rate
adjustment would potentially happen like
in comparison with with the rate of
return
to the extent that if this went through
at a 25 million year appropriation for
10 years and some of that not that and
that total amount wasn't needed to to
pay the benefits accrued here that would
be what's called an actual real gain and
it would lower employer contribution
rates you know all in group two for all
both state and local right the anything
over you know is it well you know moving
all the other assumptions are met any
extra money we over and you know
anything in the 25 million that doesn't
is over what's needed to fund this is a
tax reduction to the municipalities you
know and it it saves you interest in the
long run and yeah you know Etc so that's
another benefit if it comes in cheaper
we get to give we get to send a bit of a
tax break down to the municipalities
yeah
that's not bad which they won't complain
about it
yep
so Chris it's the opposite of 28a you
know actually it is the opposite it's
the opposite so I mean if so that's
that's the gist of this that like I said
before there's it's as we explained in
the in the first presentation this is
this is how it was when we first
explained it so there's nothing hidden
in here there's no there's no secret
agenda there's no weird Roman numeral
that no one knows about this is
extraordinarily straightforward it is
exactly as was presented and it does
nothing more or nothing less than what
is written that was my impression I've
gone through it line by line in return
you know with the books and it is it's
exactly the same Marty's job is is if
there was something yes
so besides the cleanup
the policy changes that are made here
are
two
in a phased way delete that
table of lesser retirement benefits
and change the
um
the average the the limit on
maximum pension for people in that group
to a hundred percent of final
compensation rather than 85 percent
so that is two separate changes to the
possible pension of people in that group
one is the deletion of of lines one by
one and the other is the increase in the
um the maximum final pension as a
percent to a higher percentage of their
pay and there's one other
the one other is is that with the with
the maximum
benefit the inflation adjustment
inflation adjustment would hold true to
all folks
all folks from 2001 forward okay so that
that would be the any that's the only
change for a for someone hired July 1 of
11.
would be the pension caps because I
found it and also thank you for
reminding me yeah the policy online page
one line six and seven that is not
reducing the calculations after three
years of service correct that is that is
a policy change okay
I think we need and I and I hope my
explanation is to why I feel that needs
to be there you understand whether you
agree with it or not but you at least
understand the methodology as to why no
I I understand it and I just want to
make it
um I mean this is big enough that it
it's important to separate the policy
decisions from the language cleanup to
implement those decisions okay so we're
making a decision on the maximum final
compensation we're deleting the chart
face by face and we're limiting changes
after three years of service right
correct plus you know changing the
language to agree with those things
right
but Chris
it's a lot man we've been looking at
this a lot longer
it's like
you're speaking French to me
the number yes
250. it's 2 30. oh it is going to change
230 Maps there was a the trotty the
fiscal note on the chart of your bill
just hit a couple of days ago and it's
it was estimated at 249 it's actually
229 maximum this is going to be less
than that but but that's before we phase
it out right so what as Steve was saying
before as you keep people on another
year they're paying in they're not
taking out so that 229 is everybody Jets
right away and and joins the system
because we have added concessions it's
gonna drop that price so that was the
question I was asking is is it
potentially less than 200 I think it it
is potentially we don't have a hard
number on that so we don't know but
Finance can take care of that component
of it they'll have the number by then
they can look at it and make a
determination based off of the expense
of the bill uh our main concern here our
primary concern because we don't have
that number specifically is whether or
not the policy itself is right and good
and we think that it should move forward
and then if we can get the house to
agree with that Finance can really get
fine and then you'll have another chance
to to speak to whether or not you like
the expense of it because it's going to
go to finance come back the other point
is that the other policy decision is
that this be paid from the general fund
rather than from employer contributions
which for group two are largely for
municipalities yeah so this says that we
will pay
the approximate cost on a you know
10-year flat funded which will
first of all rather than the method we
usually use it will get more of the cost
into the system earlier which is more
effective and it will make sure that the
municipalities don't have to pay
anything for the exchange right
no doubt no downshifting
because Thou shalt not
so there may be some money
not spent
maybe and if it's not spent of the 229
that would go back to the town it would
go back to the sounds it will go into a
rate reduction right recalculate what
they pay yeah
and two two things if I may
uh so I can shut my mic off
um
I'm sure
maybe uh later on in committee
will go over those policy changes and
explain them all again
to somebody say like not a not a really
brilliant first grade person but uh
somebody who's an average first grader
will be able to explain those policies
so they could explain it to somebody
else yes either either Carol or I will
do our best to come up with some
language that's uh accessible thank you
and and I did have one more this solves
the problem
what's the problem that we just solved
so the problem
okay so so
the the prep I I will say that the the
problem this is is both a uh in my
opinion representative Schmidt a
constitutional problem and a moral
problem in the sense that
uh article 23 of the New Hampshire
Constitution says you don't go backwards
retroactive law is injurious it's
harmful and it shouldn't be done that
was added in 1784. so like in the way
that I interpret the changes that
happened in 2011 the way that the
majority of the folks that were affected
by this look at this they say hey I took
a job you told me what was going on and
then nine years later you made a change
to folks
but except that instead of just making a
change for new hires you went backwards
retroactively 10 years
that to me is a retroactive change of
Law and it flies in the face of article
23.
yep
and the changes we're making here aren't
going back in time
the changes we're making here are rip
are fixing what I interpret and others
interpret as a violation of the
Constitution this undoes the violation
and technically we're repealing statute
which we do frequently so there are laws
that are already in place this is
essentially repealing things
that that were put into so whereas the
law that was put in place before
retroactively
in injured people we're now going back
to that law and we're repealing it step
by step we're getting rid of it does
that make sense and if I are we close to
wrapping up yes you think very you think
so huh no no no I'm not in any hurry
yeah okay I I I don't have to go
anywhere Chris I I just I I do but I do
I have to go to work but I truly do
keep coming with the questions I I want
I don't want you to leave here
with not understanding something if if
now's the opportunity I have until three
so because there's another gentleman at
that table who handed out a very nice
yeah he's he's next yeah okay yeah
because okay yes awesome yeah you can
get out of here
[Laughter]
thank you representative Truth for your
procedurally you're taking this down to
OLS to get it revised correct
where are you do you have time do you
want someone else to since you're not
here I can do it I can do it right now
if I go down there right now
um so just for clarification you're
asking for things that should have been
in bold to be put in bold I would like
to see them involved gotcha
the cleanup language that was this there
this is from everything that you got
from nhrs yep we've got that figured out
and we're changing 85 percent to a
hundred percent five to a hundred I've
got that and and a couple of more you
want the last four pages in bold as well
I want last four pages involved so that
when it goes to the committee again that
they know that those are actual changes
and not in statute yeah
because I recognize some conflicts that
at least I'd like to have a draft and
have uh Community representative Pearson
let's explain it I'm amendable to that
page four
again just my clarification online line
four on page four it says for group two
members who have not attained vested
status by the January 113 the full base
rate compensation paid as determined by
the employer plus compensation over base
pay then it goes and States what the
compensation is but then if you go back
to line uh 14 it says honorable
compensation shall not include
compensation thank you yeah
for members commence service on or after
July of 2011. here go ahead Steve if I
was hired
but not because you would not be vested
prior to January 1 of 13 if you were
hired in 2012. but no it say the first
paragraph says we have not attained
vested status right prior to 13. so if I
correct
so it covers the if you're in 12.
no no it doesn't because you did not
obtain vested staff no that's what I'm
saying it's it's never mind you go ahead
so so what what that the the line two
the earnerable compensation who commits
service after July 1 of 11 that's
already statute that's not a change that
that's already in the in the RSA
so
there's no there's no change there
for the first that January on line five
you're going to be changing that date
the vested date
so that it'll start
if you're hired after July 2011
you do not get to include comp extra and
special pay period ever so so to
translate this out of a vested world
into a hiring world
this the first sentence says for group
two members hired prior to January 1 of
2003.
in essence that's what that says one of
them's best said the others hired
because because that's what if it takes
10 years to best
then that's generally one of O3 is right
is a vesting of January 1 of 13.
does that make sense it's the same thing
just said two different ways
with the without getting into the Weeds
about turning 65 and all the little tiny
things that can exist but for the most
part
that's that's what that is so so like so
paragraph two is is not a change that
that's already in statute I'm looking at
that reads members who were hired prior
to January 1 of 03. and then next year
it would be January 104 and then January
1 of 05. because they they need 10 years
to get vested
and then line 14 has to do with when
they start working not when when they're
vested
I hate the term I wish we didn't use the
term vested status yeah but because of a
couple of rare conditions that exist
under the retirement rules right now
we're stuck with it I would prefer to
just have a hiring date does that does
that make sense to you
they still look
at it yeah
yeah reading it seems complicated it
could be because of technical things
with how we have to write it it that
line for Steve said could read for those
who
um hire after all well yeah a commenced
service on or after January 1 of 2003.
and I wish it could but that is military
little things in there that but it does
it does cover the concern that you have
people people are covered
the first paragraph is how compensate
comp over base is calculated for anybody
who is invested period and then the next
paragraph takes out one more pay type
out of that for anybody hired after
seven one of eleven that's how that's
how it was constructed back in 11 it's
like you know they you know it's this
this and this for anybody who's not
vested oh by the way anybody who started
after this this isn't in there either so
that that construction-wise that that is
even though it's
um bold italic here that's actually the
current statue yep
yeah of course go ahead
correct that is the one date that has to
remain the same because it is how much
time did you have based on January 1 of
12. if you were to move that you would
have a moving chart right that cannot
exist in the way that this is being
removed because that is the one place
that it must remain that date that that
that date there that 2012 indicates how
we read the chart so on 12 if you have
one year of service which would push you
out to the 13. and if you and if you
look at the at the legalese at the back
that does the annual shifting
it refers to that
specifically exempts the the table pair
the table I forget the word he uses but
it's
uh except table heading except table
heading because the table heading cannot
change it has to stay that would that
would unravel this whole thing if the
table heading changed that could get fun
on page
six on page eight because on line 34
you've stopped taking those vehicle you
they they have to be there so we can
take them off they also have to be there
in case somebody does choose to leave
prior to the implementation of this
there has to be a way to calculate their
benefit
if they choose not to have take the
incentive and do the other year
otherwise there'd be no guidance it's
just how that would work yeah that makes
sense
thank you very much oh of course any
other questions
okay this is this
stuff is so complicated that anybody who
asks a question will probably Enlighten
everybody in the room yeah
I I do want to
um just thank representative Pearson
this is
really very well done and for my from my
perspective I don't know how Jeff feels
about it but I like it
that's it all right all right very good
uh it's three three weeks of no sleep
yeah
and I still and I'm still going to OLS
right now yeah so and to everybody
everybody who's in the room we we do
have we do want this to work
um for sure and we want to make sure
that it's written correctly so if we run
into anything that we feel like is
compromising the goal we'll make sure
that it gets fixed along the way but
this looks really solid so nice job yes
and the the point of the phasing is to
provide a
a
incentive for people not to retire
immediately and to continue to work
because we value all of the
contributions and we don't certainly
don't want to start trying to hire
all the high-level policemen in the
state at some point you know it's we'd
like to stretch it out over a few years
yeah thank you for your service guys
really do appreciate it all right Steve
thank you so much and I'm just going to
give the photo Marty for a little bit so
he can go over all of his stuff
and just so everybody out there knows
this next section won't have anything to
do with the amendment it's more
education on how this pension system
works so that people can understand it
better
yeah Mr thank you for joining me
I'll give give Chris a few minutes
should we take a vote right now do you
want to take a vote on it right now oh
we can't because we don't have that
finalized Amendment right
right yeah
yeah because I had a bunch
um and uh I think I think after another
week representative Trill be the pension
expert you know in the house caucus so
um so so I had sent the full committee a
handout uh yesterday in the email you
probably yep yes so so
yeah so so what that and I think he may
have copies if either of you folk gents
don't you know okay
um so so what I what I try to do here is
I you know show the current oh
okay
sorry oh oh no problem and I mentioned
this to the to the subcommittee chair
earlier uh you know with respect but
actually uh yes Peter uh gentlemen uh we
have to continue on with our work uh if
you'd like to have conversations that's
fine but if you could please take them
into the hall for us that would be great
um so just just with respect to the
committee I mentioned this to the chair
earlier but
um I'm actually off now and I had made
plans in the fall to go out of state
this weekend so I kind of have to leave
a little bit after that sorry Marty if
you suspend for just a gentleman with
all due respects so if you if you want
to continue talking to me
but I can come back next week if needed
to to go through things but this this
handout that I sent over
to the committee yesterday it shows the
benefit uh structures the tiers as they
exist today
um just as a comparing contrast with the
um
you know with the changes to any
Amendment so just just for the sake of
brevity you know we'll say tra members
vested prior to 1-1 of 12. uh trb or the
folks affected by the amendment today
and then TRC this is anyone hired on or
after July 1st of 11. nothing changes
for them you know in the current
Amendment so essentially you know the
benefit formula for the tra the old plan
folks if you will is the minimum age and
service to retire is 45 age 45 with 20
years of service you'd have to hit both
of those so you could have somebody who
doesn't get their 20 until they're 50
years old depending on when they start
but you have to hit both of those
minimums uh this is you know still quite
a number of them still active in the
system and when they retire that's their
average final compensation and I'll talk
about how that has changed as well
multiplied by two and a half percent
multiplied by their service time so the
example here for this traum or is it if
they had an average final compensation
of 80 000 times 0.25 you know is 2 000 a
year times 20 years you know working 20
years would get them fifty percent of
their average final compensation
100 exactly yeah yeah just you know and
um and now there's an important
difference in the examples I I put here
um
you know I used 80 000 as a baseline for
comparison say just just for that but
the definition of earnable average final
compensation as well as earnable
compensation are both different for
members in tier B and tier C that's
those are some of the changes addressed
in in representative Pearson's Amendment
and those are the things that can't be
changed after three years going forward
in the amendment but so so basically you
know the changes made in 2011 cut out
types of pay that count towards the
pension and put additional calculations
on how much uh money above your base pay
that you can receive that counts towards
your pension obviously if you earn it
you're going to get those dollars some
of the big things in that and we could
really get into the the microscopic
level but some of the big picture things
is with earnable compensation is pay for
accrued unused sick and vacation time
you know depending on the employer and
depending how long somebody's there they
could have you know 10 20 weeks vacation
or you know some some employers pay out
for unused sick you either total or on a
parata basis so you know it's a nice
little chunk you know at the end of your
career and for the tra members that's
part of the average final compensation
piece so it's averaged over three years
um so that that goes into their final
pension calc for anybody in tier B or C
they may get that money from the
employer if the contract calls for it
but that isn't reported to nhrs and it
doesn't factor into their benefit so
that's a big change there's another one
with average final compensation called
comp over base there was a bill last
year to address it somewhat for group
two tier B
um you know there was that the let the
state put the money up front to correct
that I think it was about 43 million but
but you know the big picture thing you
want to just think of is a average final
compensation and earnable compensation
changes
among the tiers and it basically gets
less and less so so when you're doing
these these sample calcs the AFC is in
apples to apples in some ways so
probably going pretty deep there so
and then if you turn to page two this is
trb this is the folks that this bill
addresses the uh 436 addresses with this
amendment and when the law was changed
New Hampshire chose to retroactively you
know change benefits for people who are
in the system but not yet vested that's
the whole sort of
you know reason we're here today
like we had a gentleman from Corrections
who has since left the room who started
in January of o2 so he had nine years
and 11 months when the law changed so
um so so that you know so so you know so
that that's how that worked that and
this shows what basically among the
other than the compensation calculation
changes they added a year of age and an
added a year of service to the minimums
to retire and also reduce the multiplier
on a sliding table so that that person
who was hired in 2002 rather than
retiring at 45 with 20 years at two and
a half percent a year they after retired
no no earlier than age 46 with 21 years
multipliers you know 0.1 less and it
sort of slides down so the sample count
on this page just show those right now
there's four levels in this table the
representative Pearson's moving it to
nine levels but you know the calcs there
so essentially even
keeping the flat AFC you know the
pension benefits are set of forty
thousand there forty thousand three
hundred forty thousand four eighty so so
you're working another year two three or
four basically to get the same benefit
that a tra member gets if they retired
at 45 with 20. so so that that's how the
current
structure is works and and um
you know in what this bill would do is
on a year by year basis phase the people
who are into your beer tier B back into
tier a so that
um that person who started in 2002
um if the bill passes as of next January
1st 24 his his new minimum age and
Service retirement requirement for
retirement would have been 45 and 20 his
multiplier for his career would be 2.5
instead of 2.4 and those end of career
payouts and you know uh you know uh
calculations that camp down the average
final compensation go away and he's
retiring basically under the old plan
okay and and that and that every year
you know one more one more group of
people who were hired in that calendar
year
become eligible to retire under tra so
instead of doing it all at once so
everybody who is you know hired between
2002 and July 1st of 11 could go out at
45 and 20 as soon as they hit it they
have to work a little bit longer I I was
talking to representative Pearson
just before he had to leave because I
had an email and a phone call from
representative Abeer this morning she
had a question about well how many years
do people have to work and that came up
earlier in the conversation so so the
way the changes are phased in if you
were hired in 2002 so you're right at
the you know the nine years plus in trb
right now you miss investing by that
much
um next year the vested by date would
change to 1 1 of 13. okay and that's
effective on January 1st of 24. so
somebody hired in 20 2002
would have had has to work you know 22
between 21 and 22 21 point something in
22 years to retire so they have to
hang around longer you know uh by a year
then as representative Pearson indicated
earlier and
that that
so so the phasing in here creates a de
facto you know 22 years of service is a
minimum for everybody because the way
the way the timing of the bill is
you know and I I say 22 in round numbers
but it depends on what when in the year
you started but so
um and so the the this is where it gets
a little complicated and this is why I
just want to check with him first so you
know the folks hired in 2002 and 2003 so
they had less than 10 but more than
eight years when the law changed
um you know they can retire at 21 years
so literally yeah some of that
um hypothetical gentleman I I cited can
we could have retired February 1st under
the current Provisions had he chose so
he's going to have to wait till next
year if this goes through to get the the
different benefit count and then the
next uh transfer of people were those
hired
um with
um less than eight but more than six
years and that's 47 and 22 for those
people so they still have to work 22
years
to get it and then so every everybody in
this in the tears right now is going to
have to work 22 years before they can
retire and that's two years more than
what the law said when they were hired
it was 20 years when they for these
people you know the law changed and the
people on the tail end of this have to
work 23 or 24 years to be eligible it
reverts back to 22 for them but it's
it's still
more year they still have to work more
years than they would have had the plan
never changed you know back in 2011 so
that it's
yeah it's a it's a complicated concept I
mean you know so it's it's essentially
moving year by year group you know a
couple hundred people back into tra
um you know over over a 10-year period
so that is the most complicated thing I
had to tell you so um I'm sure you may
have some questions and and if you got
that I'm going to give you an apple and
an A plus
um
is any of this affect people who are
retired now no
no
um
is this 200 million dollars whatever
number that's going to figure out to be
is is that only for basically for the
you know
to help pay for the Tia be
yeah yes
it's not it's not for Tia a
it's 250 million dollars for 1700 people
foreign
population in the in the tier B so yeah
that yeah
and peer
Tia B
keeps getting smaller
right because the people move out of
the the this is based on basically when
how many years of service they had at
January 1st of 2012. so so it's a fixed
population I can't get any bigger you
know when people retire or pass away
that's the only way it can get smaller
or if they quit before they've you know
before they're eligible to collect a
pension and come back later and get it
you know those you know people and
because it is a pension where we're
estimating value per person over
potentially
20 years 30 years 40 years so each
individual year is you know obviously
not nearly as much but if somebody lives
40 years then that benefit that
additional benefit is quite a bit of
money
um from from a pension standpoint
I'm going to guess that you in school
you probably were pretty good in math
other than geometry I'm taking a stab at
this that was painful if uh if it were
up to me no there'd be something a
little extra in your paycheck next week
sadly sadly it's not up to me thank you
thank you very much if this is in
YouTube I'll show this to my boss next
week
um so so
um yeah that thank you
I did the questions yes
it used to be
um
up on all these things
but when uh
representative speaker O'Brien
took the
you know the retirement system away from
me DNA and put it in the special
committee and that was two years of
avoid when I was not hearing about this
all the time so even though I have even
though I do recall the situation where
suddenly reshuffled the deck on that
group of people who were
more than nine years but not quite 10
years
and and so forth and they really did get
the reluctable dog from underneath them
but suddenly they were going to have to
work an extra year or so
for the same amount of money
and that delayed their return their
ability to re-retire with with the
benefits uh that they promised
the extra year basically what was maybe
even a little bit more kind of for free
right
I I do recall being across the hall
and
we were sitting up here and there were
you there Marty
oh the back of the room was full of
guys don't look like
you guys were 30 years
[Laughter]
well and to me
to clarify though Peter
they were still employees but to clarify
this because this is important when we
say they had to work another year for
the same amount of money some people
might throw up their hands and say so
what
they still had to pay into the system
for an additional year so money is being
taken out of their paycheck for that
extra year in order for them to get the
benefit it's not just like how we're
just going to delay it for a year and
then you can get the same benefit you
were going to get if that had been the
case people probably would have rolled
their eyes a little bit like whatever
but some of these other guys had to work
an extra two years three years four
years paying into the system having
money taken out of their paycheck to get
that benefit so that that can be
confused when you're looking at this
chart because you're like well so if
they were in tra and they made 80 000 on
average then they're going to get a 40
000 but a year they have to work an
extra year and they get an extra 320
bucks so what's the big deal well you
know that 12 or 13 000 that they had to
pay in to get there is a big deal if you
go down to the next one well that other
twenty four thousand dollars that they
had to pay in to get that is there you
know like so it's it just compounds as
it goes along right well there were a
lot of guys who were
they had a very Gloom look on their
faces and I remember Steve Pearson
sitting there and so I do remember his
friends a lot of unhappiness
uh and so this
this new plan uh restores some
activities of people
that was not all of it I said some yeah
at least there was some Equity to those
people so it's it's the right thing to
do it's not a full
that's important for the following us
be made conscious of uh and you remain
conscious of that restores some of the
lost you know Equity but not all but
it's it's better than nothing absolutely
it's also a common story about the
people who have been sort of that they
are willing to compromise and come to
the table and not demand whatever I
think they're willing to get this model
State and uh in this particular
situation highly of their their
integrity so
um because they could I mean everything
email me to remind me to send you one
well I mean
the legislature you know made a mistake
a long time ago in leaving a system in
place
uh that was only supposed to be there
for a very short
period of time to give some relief to
the to the employers to the to the towns
and so forth and that got left in place
and it did a lot of damage to the system
to the point where I was reading
stop for 15 000 in 2007 actually but
when when the legislation decided
in the 90s
yeah it was it was a temporary solution
and acted in 91 that stayed on the book
still 07. you know
during that time oh yeah I remember
seeing the chart and the challenge of
paying like 1.3 and that's how we ended
up are we still in committee
that's it should we be turning on the
mics
not official but we can all right yeah
yeah I don't know I mean at this point I
don't know that it really matters I can
though um
yeah but so we're not just looking at an
issue from 2011 this issue
the the reason why they did what they
did in 2011 is because of what the
legislature did from the 90s to the
early 2000s and and that's why we have
the uaal because the municipalities
weren't paying enough money so we
weren't getting the return on the money
that was supposed to be going in which
is why I mean I don't know what to get
up to its peak it was almost 11 billion
or 9 billion yeah the unfunded liability
we topped off a little just just north
of six
it's like 5.7 a little bit under 5.7 now
yeah and if I'll put on my my uh fence
straddling retirement system hat to sort
of sum up
um 2011
um you know you know it's it's like I I
think it's fair to say that legislative
enactments in 2011 were a reaction to
some of the funding mishaps in the 90s
plus the Great Recession whether they
went too far or not far enough is not
you know that that's people can have
their own opinion on it but I think the
reasoning behind that was of sins of the
past and they were trying to catch up
and and whether that was too extreme or
not you know you'll hear different
arguments from different people but I
think everybody who was here earlier
will tell you it went too far yeah well
I mean it was
until uh until it was recognized what
the situation was because we were told
that we were 125 funded back in the days
under the this temp so-called temporary
situation it's only supposed to be there
for a couple of years got left in place
uh and we were told we were 125 funded
and so we said oh great I wasn't here at
that time but but that's that's where
that was it was explained to us uh and
uh so we created special account
we as a source of funding for college
but also to pay for uh to subsidize a
health care plan that was in place
and suddenly when it was realized we
weren't a 25 funding uh and we were
going over the cliff and we had to turn
everything around to save the system for
everybody yeah we had to absorb those
other accounts yeah Chris I know you
have to go so I just want to give you
like a little softball that I thought 2
30 2 30 this morning
all right so we've got a I'm just
throwing out numbers I don't care how
accurate they are five billion unfunded
liability you're gonna pay off uh 10
years after I'm no longer here
um but how are you going to do that
because you can't
whiz how are you coming up with five
billion is is that on the backs of the
employers now yeah yes the employers
pay the full responsibility for funding
the liability the way the plan is set up
so
um a couple weeks ago we did our
orientation the the of the percentage
the employers are paying I think it's
about 14 for employees a little bit
under 20 for teachers and 27 28 for for
police and fire
75 to 85 percent of that
employer rate is paying down the
unfunded so so basically the the we're
capturing you know you're paying it's
basically think of it as an interest
payment you know that they're and it's
it's part of the rates it's going to be
high through 2039 when most of the
unfunded is going to be paid down uh
there's sort of a safety valve for
future gains and losses so we may you
know it's
you know if a plan was at a hundred
percent funded at you know 11 52 you
know on February 10th you know it could
be underfunded in a minute depending on
how the market goes or over funded so
you know you want to be close to 100
because that you have a lot more
flexibility with benefit construction
too because you're not accruing
liabilities if you change things and the
rates are going to be lower
um but um you know we're we're
the the rates are a percentage of
payroll so as salaries increase just you
know you know through inflation or
contract increases employers are paying
that same unfunded rate for another
through 2039 you know and that's gonna
every year money's coming in it's being
invested so we're hopefully earning
interest on that on a long-term basis
that's how we're going to get to the 5
billion you know to pay that down so
that that's that's
oh worry I turned I turned the softball
into like a you know a 3-2 you know one
account before before I took the lock
but uh so yes the municipalities pay it
yeah and then and it's either the
employer yeah and if the the rates of
Investments don't don't meet what we are
expecting them to meet then the rates
for the municipalities will go up at
some point to compensate and vice versa
so if we over perform right now then the
rates should go down a little bit but
um until 2039 when the uaal is at
arguably 100 funded and then the rates
for the municipality should drop
straight through the floor that's the
goal I'll be sure I'll be looking down
saying oh yeah
I was there I was
I was oh really JC I was there
um
on the original bill it talked about
teachers this has nothing to do this has
nothing to do with teachers just group
two
and that's and that's some of the stuff
that's
we're gonna not see teachers in the
amendment right correct yeah yeah and
and that went both ways um there were
some group one language and group two
areas and some group two languages of
group one area so um those have been
caught though we're gonna get rid of
that stuff so we will have to meet again
probably before
um committee work next Wednesday because
we'll have the final Amendment at that
point
um I'm gonna call it for like 9 30 or 9
40 probably just a few minutes so we can
sit down and say here it is it's clean
um I'll get it to you beforehand so you
can vet it if you want to make sure
everything looks good but I'll vet it
line by line myself and then we'll vote
on it and then it can go to exact later
because it's got to be exact to that day
out of committee
um next Wednesday so with that guys
we're done here today thank you so much
for your time I think the calendar
oh is that what it says
oh Carol are you booked one
[Laughter]
oh that makes sense yeah I guess 1pm
makes sense
foreign